the strength of the euro is given by the
strong
the European Central Bank has on the
Bible's it in order of the new countries
to be part of the eurozone they have to
respect certain strict parameters which
would allow which to have an imaginative
of behaviors of the single governments
so that there are not shocks you know in
one country and there are no I the euro
is it takes a long long time to be part
of the time and effort from each single
kinda to be part of the year I think
that the strength of the earth doesn't
come from all the weakness of the year
doesn't come from a single specific
country but the overall European
countries that participate to the
eurozone